in this video you will learn what a blog
spot is which information
can be read in a box there and
then we will look at what we have
learned using an example and with
that i would say let's start right
away box space is used in the
statistics to at a glance
to represent various parameters graphically
that is
why it is so difficult to understand bob space at the beginning
then a diagram immediately provides a
lot of information about the
data in a box
there you can read, among other things, the median of the
inter-quarterly distance of the range and the
departure but don't
worry there  we'll go into that in more
detail in a moment it's not difficult to
understand the data used must be
metric sky levels such
as a person's age
annual
household electricity consumption or temperature often
a bock plot is drawn up by two or
more groups  compare and
contrast
to the beis  game the salary of men and
women have now let's look
at what we can read off a sheet of paper
after that we go through what we have
learned using an example
the box itself indicates the area in
which the middle 50 percent of all values
lie  the lower end of the box is
therefore the first quarter and the upper
end is the third quarter, so
25 percent of the data is below cow and 25 percent of
the data is also above well in
the box, then 50 percent of the actions are
let's say we look at the age  of
people in a box there and q1 is
19 years old then it means that 25 percent of
the participants are younger than 19 years old
if q3 is 55 years old then it means that
25 percent of the participants are older than 55
years old 50 percent of the participants
are accordingly between  19 and 55
years between q1 q3 is the
inter-quarterly interval in the box plot
, the solid line indicates the
median and the dashed line indicates the
mean value  n the median, for example,
34 means that half of the
participants are younger than 34 years old
and the other half are older than 34 years
is still 1.5 times the integrative
distance what does that mean now
here we see the inter-quarterly
distance the t-shaped lawyer the maximum value of
your data but a maximum of 1.5 times
the integrative distance so if
you have an outlier then the t works
shaped whiskey is up to 15 times the
discoverer team distance if there is
no outlier then the usk is
the maximum value so the top t shaped
whiskey is either the maximum value
or 1.5 times the discoverer team
distance whichever
is smaller exactly the same applies  for
the lower USK the corresponds to either
the minimum or 1.5 times the
winter quarters distance points which are
further than 1.5 times the de  s inter
quarterly distance ling are
considered outliers ligue 1 point
further than 1 5 times the
winter roost distance away
the t-shaped whiskeys indicate the maximum
or minimum value so
and we’ll look at that with an
example for this we’ll go on date
up de you can find the link in the video
description of copying our own
actions in this table
here we have a data set in which
each patient there was documented by a
patient in a hospital
after each fall they
were asked where in the city took
place to which  time of day which
gender the fallen person had
what the result of the fall was and the age of
the person if we now click on age
we get the bock spot for
the age we see that the maximum value is
92 years and the minimum value is six
years q1 is 29 therefore is now
six to 29 years 25 percent of
people and between 29 and 65 5 are
50 pr  occent of people between 65 5
and 92 are accordingly the top
25 percent the mean is 45 43 and
the median is 42 therefore half of the
fallen patients are younger than 42
and the other half are older than 43
years if you like you can see here
you can also change the direction you
can display all points
and also
display the standard deviation the standard deviation is then
drawn with a triangle if you click
on the title or the axis
labeling you can
easily change this you can change the colors and font sizes under settings
if you now enter the age and the place of the fall in
a text then each group gets
its own box space so she can now
clearly compare the different groups
you see the
mean value and the median of the individual
groups again and you can read off the area in which
the individual  scatter groups
i hope you liked the video and
we see  goodbye next time